[Applause]
very much look at you what a crowd
I know why you're happy tonight I know I
always say this but this is really good
Derek Jeter ended his big career at
Yankee Stadium last night with a
game-winning hit in the bottom of the
night didn't take that Isis
oh yes America is still having a full-on
panic attack about Isis and who can
blame them they released a new audio
Isis did it said you will not feel
secure even in your own bedrooms
oh no that's the NSA I'm sorry I knew is
one of the other but don't worry about
Isis Obama is getting his full George
Bush on he as he started bombing a new
country all his own Syria and he went to
the UN and called them a network of
death I thought that was CBS but okay
and he's gotten all the other countries
involved he got five Arab monarchies
involved the British are doing it now
they're with us they're always with us
they're the Lindsey Graham to our John
McCain you know and Belgium
Belgium's on board watch out Isis
Belgium is with us and they don't waffle
of course when I say these countries are
with this you know they aren't really
helping us take the fight to Isis
they're accompanying us on these
missions they're flying alongside it's
it's kind of like when a woman says
she's shopping with her husband he's not
really shopping he's holding the purse
that's really what's going on it but of
course this bombing of Syria is a little
awkward because a year ago we were gonna
bomb Syria but we were gonna bomb the
other guy we were gonna bomb President
Assad and now we're his Air Force yeah
we're bombing his enemies doesn't mean
we like Assad we just love bombing that
and we're not just bombing Isis over
there we're bombing the new hot
terrorist group if you heard about
Khorasan isis is so five minutes ago
could it's all about Korah chorus on a
week ago I thought it was the new
restaurant in Beverly Hills
Corazon that's right I tell you our
pilots are so used to bombing people in
the Middle East that we can call them up
in the middle of the flight and say hey
you know what why you're out um would
you mind just drawing these other
[ __ ] we have in mind
No
I'm kidding we don't call them up we
text and I just and you know what we're
blowing up over there is our own
equipment that's what so no it's true
we're blowing up Isis's tanks and
Humvees that we know are good because we
gave them we gave them to the Iraqi army
and then Isis took them from the Iraqi
army so after this is all over they say
now that we're going to have to give
Iraq brand-new equipment and you know
what that means
police over here are gonna have to ride
around in last year's tanks now
the other thing we're bombing over there
is oil refineries because Isis took over
some oil refineries that's how they make
money so we're bombing oil talk about a
tough one for Republicans bombing oil
it's like asking John Boehner to fight
his bartender what [ __ ] it isn't
local
it's but bombing I must say good news is
achieving its purpose defense stocks are
through the roof
bombing is achieving its purpose defense
stocks are through the roof now it's
through the regular stock market is up
two percent in the last year but
Lockheed Boeing Raytheon General
Dynamics up 20 percent and Wall Street
has noticed Apple just announced next
year the iPhone will kill people so
we're all good on but you know what all
of this stuff tails to the great scandal
of our time are you sitting down
oh wait I can see are you sitting down
that's right
I know these people are sit again yes I
don't know if you saw what happened this
week but Obama oh my god
saluted a marine with coffee in his hand
he got off their for helicopter Marine
one and he had a coffee in his hand and
he did that so the right wing is just
flipping out because as we all know I've
said this before when Jesus sat down to
write the Constitution he he put this on
page one no saluting with coffee enough
really Reagan used to salute the
curtains are you kidding me
and if that sounded about the stuff that
America is going to hell in a hand guard
I'm sure you all saw this this week an
intruder got into the White House
a man Fox News refers to as President
Obama and to make matters worse when the
guy got in Obama saluted him with a cup
of coffee oh it was just terrible
and nobody's a maintenance the front one
made it all the way to the front door
the White House and now conservatives
are saying this is going to a Bolden
Java witness it